okay
20 seconds until the title Arena October
2022 begins
I will be playing with Zen mode so all
of my opponents names and ratings will
be hidden
why is this not synchronized
[Music]
I was slightly out oops
that was a bad start
well first round I always play Someone
Like who's right next to me in reading
so
anyway okay
Zen mode will stay on for the rest of
the tournament
but I do know I'm playing someone
rated around what seven twenty seven
hundred
not 1700.
oh is this a Magnus nepo game from World
Championship
when H5 F5 only way to defend both Pawns
man this looks kind of Josh
in very symmetrical structure
I don't want to draw so soon
I'm up a little bit of time
that's annoying
I should trade light Square Bishops not
dark Square Bishops
oh no
I want to play C5
quite slightly better here so I have the
worst Bishop
trade with me
oh
now I have the worst Rook
I'll just hold my ground
um
uh-oh
still holding on
oh it's playing really well
um
okay at least I didn't lose I think it
draws a fair result uh no reading gained
or lost
or the game oh let me um I was charging
my watch let me put on my heart rate
monitor
okay so now I actually don't know who
I'm playing
uh
great
okay after this game I'll put on my
heart rate
what
I think that was a mouse slip
[Music]
um
they're already a nice position
don't mess with my Pawn Diamond good
luck thank you
my Essential Pawn diamond
I assume you're complimenting my pot
diamonds
uh
Bishop needs to find a new home
new home achieved
at five incoming
maybe this move too
but that ruins the diamond
oh that was a free rook
okay
pawns go marching
pandemonium
so much pandemonium
or pandemonium
check
let's just keep marching
it's like Tetris so Tetris piece is
gradually falling into Lock's face
okay I'm gonna lose our Rook but that's
okay
don't mess with my Pawn storm
check
where's my mate
that was a funny line I might lose a
queen
but it's really funny so if Rook takes
Queen
I might be losing I don't know what's
the final position I'm gonna sing like
2300 2600 wow
by losing in the final position
I am oh no my queen I was just too too
fun to pass up though
um wait I have Zen mode on or off
I think I have it off or on
it should be on I haven't lost a game
yet
as this is working well so far thank you
shiggy thank you not so clear
thank you mathletic
dough okay I forgot to turn Zen mode off
so I know I'm playing someone higher
rated
uh let's take and play the sign
this is a Ray Robson variation
okay
yeah a lot of ways to reinforce the
Pawns
maybe this move
I just blundered upon
I was the one Pawn I was supposed to
defend
okay I'm down the pond
not looking good
of each three
Alpha zero Style
I'm just losing stuff
I'm trying to make things spicy
don't hurt me
I have no idea what to do
foreign
okay at least I can lose
I was losing pretty badly at that game
okay I'm turning on my heart rate
monitor
what a game
a reborn twitch baby
hey welcome back Daniel Fox
okay I need two reading points there
uh oh I was over 140 wow
so my two draws I was like I I had
little time to mate with king and queen
and king and Rook
okay
moving on
yeah this is a common idea
acts as a D3 Square
I want to play B4 I don't want to get
forked though that was a threat
I think I'm playing a pretty strong
player here
um
oh I got tricked
I resign I'm guessing 2 900.
3 000 wow I have a good position too
okay back to tournaments
I think like I
if I knew my opponent was 3 000 before
the game I would have just played worse
I would have second guessed myself
um so in that regards Zen mode helped a
little bit
I just made some unnecessary blender
there
okay that's my first loss
top 100
268 players
what
I don't think I've ever seen Queen A4
it's interesting though I mean
I know how effective it is
I was expecting Pawn takes
ooh
I think that's okay
up some nice time
I'm guessing like 2400.
okay defending both pawns with the
Knights oh I got Fort
counter attack though
I'm losing this Pawn
or not
very strange position now
hmm
okay
uh maybe 24.50
2700 man oh I played this one a lot a
lot of times before oh that's funny
that's another thing like there's some
players where I know they're opening
repertoires and when I'm playing Zen
mode
I
won't necessarily
play like play into whatever openings
that I would otherwise
okay
oh this opening again
let's play this if takes I would take
okay we have another structure like this
it's very solid
yeah I get the defended passer
hmm
confusing position now
Queen C6 is annoying again
black can't take the pawn though
because of Bishop H7 tactics
get down a bit of time here
ooh
ah
I'm in trouble
I think that was a mistake
I'm guessing 2 800.
yeah
I think that was my best guess so far
I've only played well
okay round top hundred
it's not easy to get a streak in this
tournament
because every game I'm playing a title
player
I want one staffer Gambit
okay staff for gamma time
against a mystery opponent
yeah castling's a fine move
there's still some ideas here to get
some attack
like I'm down upon but um at least my
pieces have squares
and C5 idea
maybe F6 666
not sure if this works so I'm gonna lose
another Pawn
or not
up a lot of time
oh there's a funny Queen sack line
oh no my queen
okay that was a nice game I'll guess
like 2500.
okay 2660.
castling is actually the move that I
showed Nemo like I gave Nemo a lesson on
how to quote unquote refute the Stafford
it's supposed to be solid for light Eric
thank you yellow zip
okay let me try and I don't think I've
won two games in a row this tournament
I'm gonna try and stay focused this game
I already like the opening
uh
this
hmm
B7
I really like the opening
it might be hard to guess ELO because
like a strong player could maybe stumble
into this but C4 I'll guess like 23.50
okay 22.48
okay my first two wins in a row
wait
preferences I don't know if I
reactivated Zen Moon
display
did I oh okay I see my opponent but now
I don't it's kind of like peek-a-boo
I should play 95 there
okay this is generally a pleasant line
yeah I shouldn't
okay this is actually interesting
because after he takes takes it looks
like the pawn is weak
but after Knight C5 it's actually kind
of annoying for luck
E7 attacked
maybe E4 coming
there's Pawn diamond detentional or
there's whatever this is
uh tick tick
for
eign structure
oh it's so funny
don't mess with my Pawn Illuminati
if I take I think it's okay though
three Pawn
oh good move
foreign
okay
okay I forgot my opponent's reading
20 27.80 let's go okay
oh man
there is a clutch on poisson somewhere
in that game towards the end there
okay wait Zen mode
we just have this
is that yes okay
okay
foreign
nice attacking potential here
the smooth there's also Bishop H3
there's a G5 queen or E5 Queen G5 if
takes it's made in two
like most of White's pieces are on the
queen side not defending the king
oh no my queen it's actually a cool move
because I fork and then I fork again
let's come back
the queen wanted to finish unfinished
business that was a nice game Let's
guess I don't know like 2500
okay 2600
okay 30th Place four in a row
okay another mystery opponent
you can have the Lee chess settings open
in another tab
italizes across tabs
oh what do I do here do you have to take
the things for the tiptoyota
oh tactics
man I'm down on time to
wow
so two works for a queen Bishop's vs
Knights
oh
hurt me
yeah I've all played 28.50
2700 okay
um
I won't play ball found some tactics
I still had chances after losing the
queen for the two Rooks but the a pawn
was strong
player Budapest
never mind
okay I'm playing this sign
foreign
sorry I missed you last night it's okay
I miss you too
okay that's what I was waiting for this
is force meat I would have been
smothered mate
I'll guess like 2600.
29.57 Wow Let's Go
okay back to tournament highest rated
win so far
I guess white played well apart from
like this F3 move
okay another game
stop for Gaba time
I insist
I'll play D5
yeah this is a slightly annoying line
I've had it before though like it's not
so bad in bullets
have some time Advantage here
oh
[Music]
where's my tactic
does this work no that doesn't work
um
to go for this down the piece
went upon them
oh that's not good
I'm in trouble
never mind I'm still in trouble
uh let's take
oh no
ah
I'm guessing I'm gonna guess the name of
a player Fidel Corrales who's like 2700
no oh oh provisional wow
I was guessing Fidel because I've played
we've played that line before
uh Grand Master former teammate of mine
opponent played ball there
I mean I kind of I went a little bit
crazy in that uh the middle game
position
okay
haven't had one of these yet Joe Bava
London against sort of a grunfeld King's
Indian setup
I can take
some B4 idea
um
everything's hanging
wow
I think this is okay the knights look
kind of loose
F6 was not a good move
like this
oh it's really close to meat
okay Knights are hugging the king
or sandwiching the king want to play
this and then B5
that's such a funny it's not quite mate
though
um
okay
I'm trying to make art
five
check
where's the meat
oh
I forgot umpassan was legal
oh no I might lose this
yes
wow
oh that was dirty welcome back to Bob 10
months I'll guess 2600.
okay
wow
I was really looking for a funny mate it
was so close and then I spent all my
time
and then blundered all my pieces
but I held on to the tricky night
okay
uh let's play this Budapest
Budapest Canada time
yeah this is a fun one
everything's hanging for lights
Knight D3 almost defends everything
so I'm threatening this
I'm also still threatening this
Knight is hanging but I like had other
problems
so now I want to trap The Rook actually
Bishop C2
and then
essentially I'm trapping The Rook
that was a funny line
I could move
96.
oh
almost dropping the Knight but not quite
and I can
[Music]
um
oh no my Bishop's trapped
one's playing well
don't mess with my horsies
foreign
I think I missed a fork there
oh no
oh yes
let's declare the win for me because a
knight is mating material when the phone
has a pond
uh August 27-50
okay
I'll take it two in a row
yeah that was kind of dirty but it's a
nature of bullet like
sometimes that's what games come down to
okay we have a pierce
this moves uh
one of the go-to plans
I see two hangs actually it doesn't
hitting the bishop
play C3
[Music]
hitting the pawn
don't want to trade Queen so soon
I guess I have to
oh I got fort
keeping the knights
because Knights are trickier
there's a funny line where I trapped the
bishop Bishop D2 King E2
I have plungers upon
wow
wow August 2700
2574
okay that's three in a row back on the
streak
that was a tricky game
especially after I got forked and lost a
piece
okay one of these lines ah this line so
E4 is a funny move
which I think I can play right away
I know E4 after G6
uh what's this
okay I got Forks let's sack this might
be wrong
it's almost certainly wrong
it looks fun though
kind of like a inspired
inspired by Halloween
if I take
oh
good move before
it doesn't do anything
I'm in trouble I'm telling the piece I'm
down a ton of time
good move
oh no
I'm not a rook
another good move
oh
that's not even
uh I thought the planet Mouse slips but
the point just discovered checked me
okay I'll guess 2800.
oh I was playing rasulov
okay I think my guesses are are better
today
I mean it helps to know that I'm playing
title players
okay top 40. not bad
I think I've been gaining rating a
little bit
oh I played the wrong move order
you gotta play this
this is a fun line actually this is a
more positional line
wow
this is hard to judge what's happening
wow
wow that's no longer harder to judge
yeah Bishop C3 would have
been winning I mean this is also pretty
bad for me
oh my king
uh two
27.50
okay
I played Lance a lot I think I beat
Lance a lot earlier
and that's my first double loss in a row
let me try and break this streak
hi Eric what's your preference to
hangout in a park a bar or a coffee shop
coffee shop
or ideally a tea shop
I think this is okay
winning a pawn maybe lock has some
compensation
but maybe not
black has a bishop pair
what
how's this oh that was clever
okay
um
okay exchange sock this is intentional
because I fixed my structure
I get some gigapons
that's risky though Bishop's not so
great
hitting this Pawn
I'm winning a rook back can you hear if
it's a skewer King here it's a fork
blocks really tied down
okay that worked out really nicely
uh 2600
okay guesses have been going well
I broke my losing streak which is nice
staff or Gambit time
South Africa time
oh this sign this is a fun one
King D2 Knight H2
right there
I go take
a little bit more uh quiet position now
uh E5 coming
uh
it's ugly position
oops that was a mouse up actually
okay I'm fighting for a draw basically
Rook G5 I think I can take it
and King catches a pawn
this might be losing but it turns into a
pawn race
what's happening
uh I'm down in a few Pawns
I'm already smelling it though
already smelling it
oh
yes
I smelled it from a distance there let's
go
okay uh I mean white played well I'll
guess like 27 is 70.
okay 27 21.
the first stalemate trap of the Stream
okay 50 first place
and D5 I can also just sack let's just
sack looks fun
okay seven a seven and E7 are both
targets
oh the sack pack
take your first
now this doesn't work there's Rook F6
okay at least I have this
so I'm down a bishop for a few Pawns
actually have three pawns and now a
queen
okay uh 25.50
oh wow 2556 let's go
oh
that was a weird game
okay this is a pretty good version of
London
I'm already thinking my oppon's like a
lesson
2500
nice time Advantage nice position maybe
I should not have castled
that's like very pleasant
G4 G5
yeah when black plays E6 in the wrong
moment in London this bishop gets stuck
and uh yeah white has all the fun
[Music]
I want to maneuver to F6
black is holding on though
now it's kind of annoying
I guess I'll take and just before
oh that four is hanging
I guess like 24 20.
oh no my queen
actually I should not have sacked the
queen like that
oops
24 20. 26 13. okay
yeah I guess just a nice position from
the opening there
okay 44th Place haven't lost a game
and the last four
okay I'm playing this Gambit this is a
fun one
like this new trendy Gambit I actually
discovered this line like five or six
years ago
that's been pretty trendy recently at
like top GM level play
yeah Knight's actually kind of trapped
on G3 surprisingly
thanks to the new Subs
appreciate that
I'm just gameting the pawn
now I'm gabbing this Pawn
white doesn't want to take my Pawns
hitting the bishop
winning a bishop
I guess 2500.
oh white blendered back but it's okay
now I'm only on the exchange
it's not so simple to win I do have the
time advantage
yeah King wants to come in
oops did I just do
I got completions
oh
clutch Pawn
clutch Pawn
what did I guess 2500 27 Oh there's
Lancelot play Lancelot now three times
this tournament
wow
oh man
we might have time to pre-move that too
I was slow in the end
okay Mainline London
uh and I have three
like the main main line
yeah this is actually my prep for Tanya
I am not a GM match
I have a bunch of games in these lines
I think this is already positive for
whites because I want a pawn
E5 comes
E5 yeah
the epon's pinned
that's a good move though
if takes is made into
[Music]
I want to play H3
done a lot of time here
[Music]
clean defense
okay I'm winning the pawn
that was not necessary
thanks for the raid hey it's just bra
what's up chess bro
if you're just joining I'm trying to
dirty flag my opponent
uh
duh
I was so close to still need to
oh to do oh who did I play also for
everyone joining I'm playing in Zen mode
so my last game
was against a 2614.
yeah normally I try and do guess ELO
yeah shout out to chaspora welcome
everyone
[Music]
um this is a titled Arena on niches
for every game I'm hiding the name and
reading of my opponents
it's Gus to ELO in real time
Pleasant position
defending and getting out of the pen
getting back into the PIN
oh Queens don't I tried to save my queen
but I moved it to uh still attacked
so I have night for queen
I don't know who I'm playing I mean I
could be playing a complete beginner so
I might as well play on
but they're probably not a complete
beginner
uh oh
stop hurting me
okay I'll guess
27 70.
2900 oh I was playing Michael
good game
oh yeah this is a title Arena so I'm
probably not playing any complete
beginners
oh to do
okay I lost the last two in a row still
top 50. 39 tournament points
and leader has 69. nice job to portnick
oh this is already questionable
some unintentional Gambit here
night trout night's almost trapped but
yeah there's a
have I castled there was a bishop D6
winning The Rook
so I'm down upon
it could be worse
okay I'll provoke the trade
because Rook D4 in the end
oh good move
oh no
I could have gotten skewered there
that's a pin
foreign
okay I win because I have mating
material uh 2600 27 Oh I was playing
Lance a lot again oh wow
I should come to learn lancelot's
openings
and plays the English a lot I like the
way you play even if it doesn't always
work out
keep it up oh I like the way you sub I
think you Brendan
okay another one of these I could be
playing the same opponent never mind
play H4
so one plan is Queen G3
the point of having the pawn here is
there's no Knight H5
there's also each six potential
um
H6
F6 CM
oh G6
takes
to do G4
oh this is not good
G4 here
don't hurt me
stop hurting me
oof I'm getting hurt
Blockhouse connect five
but I have a blockade
what a crazy position
ah
uh I don't know this I guess 2 800. 2
900 wow ah
I like my position out of the opening
thank you Ralph Talia
okay still top 50.
uh let's play this
foreign
defend that
[Music]
um
this is terrifying
also threatening to trap their Rook with
this move
multi-purpose move
wow what a move
thank you
if this works looks interesting though
let's go wow is Rook H1 for his mate it
might be I'm guessing 2800
okay 27 38.
real quick
um 10 months
mean six
if I don't play Rook H1 then White's
better that's insane because White's
threatening mate
I was a bit tied down
okay back to tournaments thank you
honokicks
still top 50.
trying to get back on a streak
man my reading's been going up which
usually doesn't happen in these like
longer Arena tournaments
I think Zen mode is probably overall
good for my chess dupes
I forgot to turn back on Zen mode
so I know I'm playing someone decent
uh it's Castle first
go for E4
it's already looking pretty good
Bishop C4 ideas
F7 is a weak points
tick tick tick
I think this works
I mean tactics are like flowing in every
direction
[Music]
so now the knight's pinned
foreign
crushing I could have played that
earlier too
okay 2600
27.86 oh yeah I've I even knew my
opponent's reading before the game
that's funny
I think the opponent played a little bit
weaker than the remaining there
that's a long tournament it's hard to
remember everything that's happened
those are H3
interesting
wow that's kind of annoying
I don't have Knight G4 either
just have to deal with this
this is actually kind of interesting
foreign get some kind of attack
[Music]
so I'm still down the pond
I'm turning two Pawns
I have to take
okay three would be nice I'm expecting
A4
yeah maybe it's okay for me
oh
two
interesting
I'm controlling B1 with a bishop
which is nice
also D7
finding this now
oh wow
wow that was a nice game uh 2700
2600 okay
yeah I was like I was a little bit
uncomfortable out of the opening but uh
yeah by the time the middle game came
around it was actually a pleasant
position to play
okay
let's keep going here
stop for Gambit time
ah we have this line
and stopper Gambit declined but
I should have taken on e4 and I didn't
I had this line earlier
oops
so I'm down the pond but there's some
compensation with the Bishops
for
oh fancy
Queen check
I think it's okay though Queen D5
so if takes I have Bishop B2 if takes I
take here
um
gotta move faster
foreign
oh no my zen oh no my time and my
position 2800
27.67 okay
thank you ojat
I don't know who I'm playing so I'm not
berserking back
King D7 what a funny move
oh
no mercy here
where's my funny mate
I should just move quickly
I could be playing a really strong
player who just doesn't respect me
things they can beat me berserking me
and Bong clouding me
although King G7 was a clear Mouse look
ooh fancy
have to take that
it's still fine
or is it
um
everything wins here
I'll guess like 2400.
oh timely resignation
oh oh it was backwards Magnus Carlson
let's go
oh
not quite the real Magnus Carlsen but
backwards Magnus Carlson I'll take it
strong player
okay one of these
I actually don't know what I'm doing
here
and taking over Pawn push
It looks interesting
wow
I'm winning a queen now
oh good move
um
this is annoying
oh this is actually kind of fun
yeah
the hell phone
let's go okay
uh 2 800. 2700 100 points off there
okay
44th place
okay back on the streak
two in a row
going for three
uh this one
that's a tricky line
defending attacking
that's a good move
I'm not sure about E4
in cool position now
[Music]
losing this Pawn
go after that pawn
's playing well
there's lots of a lot of pons
and a lot of pieces too
where'd all my pieces go
28.50
ah 29 okay I've only played ball that
game
oh what to do
and refocus
ah this is a point I played
disappointment earlier
oh except not quite the same line
interesting London
[Music]
thank you
it's counterintuitive I'm gonna uh never
mind I'll take a free Queen that's not
so counterintuitive
uh 2300
2600 okay
had to show no mercy with the yellow gas
there
okay 40 seconds list
55 tournament points
leader has 85 so I'm 30 points out of
the first
just trying to take it one game at a
time oh Ali Reza's playing wow
Ali Reza hasn't played one of these in a
while
okay I just win a piece in the opening
uh that's a funny move I don't think it
works
let's take a pawn
foreign
someone who berserked me probably 2 900.
oh backwards Magnus Carlsen again let's
go okay
oh yeah because they berserked me
earlier too I was uh the mouse slip King
D7 game
okay I'll take it 40th Place
thank you
the first time Prime
I do appreciate that
okay I'm definitely not playing
backwards Magnus Carlson again how's
this opening
Bishop D3 novelty
ooh
maybe it's not so bad
um
hmm
Happening Here
something made in two
wow so fancy
foreign
oh I was playing a really strong player
in there three thousand
I'm 29 21. uh
good game though I had my chances I had
a tricky night at some points
and even The Rook ending was was very
complex
I think that was a blunder because
Knight D5 is possible
we're following my game with Magnus this
um
game that I played against him in The
Silo almost exactly the same game
but not quite the same game
interesting
G6 Bishop F5
I want to control the B1 Square because
Rook supports the pawn
I want to remove the knights Knight A4
is coming
okay that's nice to see
it's still tricky though
forgot the queen was attacked
I guess I'll keep playing
no no
there's one self-stalemate actually
there's no sales stalemates
well played
uh 26.50
oh three points off
I've only played well
uh
what to do
okay still top 50.
couple losses in a row there
yeah I hung a queen I think the position
was okay before
hanging the queen
I have struggled like historically
towards the end of these tournaments it
can be hard to like be super Sharp
this was a fun line this is a really fun
line
I was already winning for whites
um start with this
over C4
I'm gonna lose the knights but uh I'm
winning stuff keep winning more stuff
okay 2300
e700
yeah it goes to show like even strong
players are capable of falling for that
trap
okay trying to rebuild a win streak
on D5 F3
oh this is a line
put the bishop on B3
ooh there's tactics here
like Rook B3 is coming
if I take I'd lose a queen
wow
it's a cool move
this move
this is terrifying though
someone call an ambulance
for me
am I escaping might be escaping
barely
opponent have voice mates at some point
how am I still alive
those ambulance arrived quickly
oh
okay someone call an ambulance again
I need more treatment
oh the move
wow how did I win that
how many moves was that
let me guess the move and the reading
uh 27 20 and 90 moves
okay 2765 moves
oh the game
I was very filthy
it was only 65 moves
I guess that average is less than a move
per second
oops okay I'm playing Brave spirits
so this is actually a fun line
there should be two I take in Queen C4
I think white messed up the move where
it was supposed to take here first
um
keep developing
maybe now Knight F3
trying to Trout the bishop
double attack
oh
very fancy
oh
okay so now I'm alive
doll
[Music]
um
well played 2700
two points off oh I already saw the
reading
ah
I forgot about that wait did I
reactivate
the nude
yes okay
here we go
foreign
[Music]
it's meant to be pushed
and Bishop defense
Queen V6
very pleasant position
got all the pawns rolling I have three
connected passers
what's a guess
24.50
oh I guessed an anagram 2540.
okay
40 second place
Luger has 99
okay less than 27 minutes left
yeah this is basically a reverse Queen's
Gambit exchange variation
interesting
almost winning upon I have five
attackers against a knight
one two three four five
turning this
I think I'm getting a fork
last king F2 wow
uh
foreign
but how
threading this now
there we go
on over
foreign
okay
40 second place
so two in a row
man I've had multiple streaks of two
wins and then
followed by a loss so let's try and get
three in a row
um
that's kind of annoying
and this is usually what I like to do is
wait
maybe G5
white plays G5
I have five ideas
it's still G5
going in some way
[Music]
I have to take
hitting the Knight
oh just plundered that
foreign
how is white so fast
I thought it was off on time at some
point
oh almost came back there what a game
uh 2 800.
not too far off
yeah light was really fast there
okay what to do 21 minutes left
foreign
London versus slav
ing this
I think not H4
looks nice
allowing Knight E4
oh
V for victory
wow
so I'm ready to take Knight's kind of
stuck
in G3
it's kind of funny
ready to get the rook in maybe
okay holding on
I should have traded
okay
2600
okay
yeah a lot of these flavors I'm playing
multiple times in a row
okay playing another random person I
think you Ender something White
appreciate the first time Prime
okay Budapest Gambit time
had one Budapest earlier
oh no my knight
if takes I take on H2 and then checkmate
uh Queen there
any funny mates
I guess the knight's coming to D5
yeah this still takes a lot of work
that was nice opening though
should still be for Choice here
you might want to do this and this
I don't know what to do take
okay hitting this and this
this is actually kind of hard to stop
simplify
uh 2500
okay
1u663 opponent just uh I mean F4 was a
pretty bad move from my out of the
opening there
was a nice Budapest game
okay 69 points
there we go again
it's too scary to berserk back when I
don't know if I'm playing
I could be playing backwards Magnus
Carlson again
or that 12900
oh
foreign
there we go that's not over though
foreign
really wanted to play this move
28.50
okay
top 40. let's go
that was a scary game like I've just
plundered a piece
I came back
oh
am I playing backwards Magnus Carlson
again
I think I am
there's a funny trick where
um
I have Queen D4 winning a knight
not quite Happening Here
this position looks really really nice
look at my giggle horsey Queen h8 97
checkmate
don't mess with my giggle horsey
off of
I'm basically up a giggle 4C oops don't
know my gig over C
okay it's still a good position though
Mercy
foreign
oh yeah the six points off with someone
else so
oops
okay 35th place
on four in a row
one of these again
I think we'll trade off everything
foreign
[Music]
yeah this is painful
ah it's really painful
don't resign when you have a horsey
who
oh it's me who has three seconds
uh 27.80
okay strong player
yeah black played that well
do I have 93
oh I missed a fork
yeah
chat sometimes spots works better than
me to do
okay no more win streak but it's not for
Gambit time
so 94 okay this doesn't work for whites
I'm pretty sure Knight F2
I looked at this like once
like cutie Cinderella had a position as
black after e594
[Music]
uh let's take this
there's a brief period in time where
cutie Cinderella was playing the staff
again it
was a funny position
[Music]
hitting with Bishop
creating this
threading the queen and mate
oh Queen D2 Rook E1
what just happened
my night's still in the corner
the Knight is very anti-social
oops
okay time to socialize
the knights practicing its social skills
okay
foreign
80.
okay 27 35.
that was a nice game
I was a funny like soccer Gambit line
too
okay 33rd Place it's a pretty good
result for Tyler Arena
I usually struggle to finish in Dot 50.
this is a fun line
now this Knight's a bit stuck
I wonder if I can play Let's play this
might see seven can come
um
wow that was a nice gift 25.50
okay 26 37
trying to get to top 30.
seven minutes left
I'm not sure if I've finished top 30
before
I probably have maybe like once once or
twice
I know there's some site that like shows
your performance history in title arenas
it's definitely been a while
oh same line as last game
except now it's a little bit different
that's a big trouble here
real big trouble
okay 2200
he's 7.50 oh I was playing Bob
oh
deserking can really decrease the
quality of play
oh this is a fun line most strong
players don't go into the sign
it's still very playable for lights
very symmetrical
I think I'm winning a pawn
hmm
oh wow does that work
might defends H7
oops
I didn't realize my Rook was hanging
2600
yeah
[Music]
uh am I just losing here
I might just be losing here actually
I had to play uh Queen da that looks
like uh what to do
yeah it's uh the end of the tournament
fatigue still top 30.
in time for a few more games
okay this is almost certainly an
opponent I've played before
been having these lines a lot today
this is already really Pleasant because
Black's not in time to
trade on A5
and once Knight A5 happens we now have
B5
um
C6
the winning upon King side down to
defending the Knight and the Knights
pinned
that's interesting
very resourceful
got Knight C5 there too
it comes anyway
okay both Bishops hanging
a nice game overall
I guess like 26.50
oh it's not over though
oops that's Chuck
that's really not over
but it's almost over threatening deadly
rookie seven
King d8 Knight B7
okay uh what did I say 26.50
almost 2800 wow I played Lancelot many
times
thus far probably my most played
opponents
okay top 30 still
time for at least one more game
closing in on 2800 too
same opening
slightly different
um
I mean Bell Castle Queen sign
playing aggressively here
I want to go for G4 G5
I should play King V1 at some point
it's a good move
King B1
have this nah
to take
a little bit uncomfortable
attack just fizzled
so shizzle my fizzle
oops
ooh
and pleasant surprise
rook's almost trapped
Rook is officially trapped
okay 27.50
okay not too far off hey that comedy for
the tournament too let's go
okay
back to tournaments
oh 27.99 oh man that was my best title
arena in a long time
and it was probably a lot of it like
things to Zen mode
because I I stopped caring about who my
opponents were I just tried to focus on
like playing good chess
I should do this more often
so performance rating my performance
rating was 28.82 wow
yeah I should really use Zen mode more
often in these tournaments
worked out really nicely